what's going on reject nation Greg he'll
be here hey hey buddy it's comedian John
I never change never changes this shirt
this is the fourth day in a row the
truth days five day five days six I
start really questioning I have three
pairs of jeans me too and I've lost
weight these are the only jeans that fit
me right now yeah yeah and because well
I think if that might be a good
indication it's time for the game that
way back with more jeans we were talking
beforehand he's pretty excited for Thor
Ragnarok yeah so we were like you know
what there's a trailer that got sent to
us I'm more excited about this than I am
for justice Lee some DC fans have
already disliked the video just because
you said that
so thanks thanks this is a personal
preference man they don't care
opinions are objective don't forget that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the ground pull me off the ground up
into the air and we fly every time I
flew you always come back - sounds like
a pretty special minute relationship
with the same ended losing was almost
comparable - all right the other things
other clips are pretty seen the whole
yeah I saw some of the the tweets that
came out for people I saw the movie
already like before the embargo is
lifted with a you should use like you
can post it about in social media but
you can't really go into it and
everyone's saying it'll be positive yeah
yeah everyone's saying this films
hilarious really yeah that's that's the
big word-of-mouth is that this film is
flat-out hysterical I'm excited for that
because I've been reading some
interviews of Chris Hemsworth uh-huh and
he was saying that he was getting kind
of bored of playing Thor hmm and he said
that what got him excited to play
thorium was doing this because it would
take a different direction bring a lot
more humor into the character and he
wants to do more comedy as you can see
just from these two clips yeah you're
like yeah it looks actually really funny
I feel like there's gonna be a lot more
likeable now because he can you imagine
being in a place in this world where you
get tired of playing for think of all
the money
a job janitors that's such a good boy he
looks incredible as a straight man it's
okay he should be like focus on their
character straight looking well yes it's
like oh man he looks good
I know it's it's kind of it's
distracting I'm like you're so
good-looking you're buff and you're
funny yeah come on
it was something to not be jealous I'm
gonna give that I'm gonna give the end
your funny part to the writers the guys
who aren't necessarily good looking at
both well guys are the funny guys I
heard that they did a lot of improv
little director loves his actors to
improvise oh really
yeah so he might just be funny meaning
you're gonna be out of a job when I
watched like movies from the 80s and 70s
and even the 90s you didn't have to be
buff yeah you know watch like Charlton
Heston like the Omega Man yeah even
Superman James Bond movies a dad but I
feel like we might get to a point now
where comedians are gonna be required to
be buff yeah I used to be the cliche of
you know if you're buff you're not funny
yeah we could having a Dane Cook yeah
maybe you might have to start getting
incredible shape now yeah I was talking
before I've only in shape to battle
battle other fathers out there
well yeah I'm excited for this throw
riding rock movie a recent superhero
yeah I'm as excited about it as justice
[Laughter]
have you seen any of this directors that
are movies like what we do in the
shadows or anything like I know
he's a New Zealand director oh yeah but
I'm American he's Canadian so we don't
watch yeah that's right we don't watch
other countries Boston you look Irish
yeah well I'm sure there was some you go
back far enough you get your DNA you got
the red yeah yeah the skin the hair you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell follow John Moses
on twitter and at comedian John Moses on
Facebook and Instagram links in
description box we'll catch you all
later